it is my pleasure to introduce you to
our guest speaker today
Professor Mark Jacobson Mark is a mark
is a professor in the Stanford civil and
environmental engineering department I'm
one of the civil and environmental
engineering department now resides in
both the Stanford School of Engineering
and the new school Stanford Dewar School
of sustainability
Mark teaches our exeit 100 course which
you can view from within our webinar
interface by selecting the link
Mark has been a champion of clean
renewable energy and working toward
ensuring air quality for all for many
decades
welcome Mark and with that I'm going to
hand the webinar over to you
thank you very much Anita for your kind
introduction
and so I'm going to talk today about
transitioning cities states countries
and the world entirely to clean
renewable energy
and
so I'm trying to get to here we go
um and so I'm going to make the point
that we don't need miracle Technologies
to solve the problems of air pollution
global warming and energy security we
have 95 of the Technologies we need
but let me first start out you know what
are these problems that we're trying to
solve and so as I've just mentioned I in
my opinion we need to solve three major
problems there's air pollution which
causes on the order of seven million
deaths per year prematurely uh worldwide
and hundreds of millions more illnesses
and this costs the world today based on
statistical cost of life and morbidity
about 30 trillion dollars per year
global warming is a rising problem it's
already seeing severe consequences and
is estimated to cost another 30 trillion
dollars per year or so by 2050. the
third problem we're trying to solve is
energy and security fossil fuels are
limited resources they will run out
eventually and we need replacement of
them in place by then otherwise we'll
see economic social and political
instability in addition the many
countries depend on fossil fuels from
other countries and so those countries
that have the source of fossil fuels can
often cause disruption as we're seeing
in Europe right now and that results in
energy and security another type of
energy and security is the fact that
fossil fuels if they're if they have to
be transported over the ocean to islands
for example that results in very high
electricity prices that's a type of
energy and security anywhere anywhere
there are several other types of energy
and security problems these are all
drastic problems that require immediate
and drastic Solutions
so our solution since 2009 when we
developed our first energy plan was to
Electrify all energy as much as we can
and then provide the electricity and
there's also some direct heat with just
wind water and solar power and we Define
wind water and solar as onshore and
offshore wind solar photovoltaics on
rooftops and power plants concentrated
solar geothermal electricity and heat
hydroelectricity and small amounts of
tidal and wave power
and if we Electrify all energy that
means there are four major energy
sectors there's electricity
Transportation Heating and Cooling of
buildings and Industry and so for
example to Electrify transportation we
go to primarily battery electric
vehicles but also some hydrogen fuel
cell vehicles for long distance
transport like long-distance ships
Planes Trains and trucks for buildings
we would go to electric heat pumps
primarily for heating individual
buildings for Air heating water heating
and also air conditioning heat pumps use
one-fourth the energy as Natural Gas
uh there's also what we call District
heating where instead of heating
individual buildings with individual
heaters and coolers we would uh have
centralized heaters and coolers and and
then transmit uh heat and cold through
water pipes to buildings uh bike is done
around the world in the United States
about seven percent of the US is already
under District heating but in some
Scandinavian countries for example it's
up to 50 percent is up under District
Heating and we provide that District
heat and cold either with heat pumps or
with direct geothermal heat or solar
heat
uh for industry we would Electrify that
primarily with electric Arc furnaces
induction furnaces resistance furnaces
dielectric heaters Electron Beam heaters
these are existing Technologies
and we power the electricity uh in all
these cases with just wind water and
solar
of course we will need storage for such
a transition we need electricity storage
some heat storage cold storage and there
will be some hydrogen for some
applications
so we already have a lot of electricity
storage options there's concentrated
solar power with storage pumped
hydroelectric power restorative which is
a storage technology existing
hydroelectric dams which are basically
big batteries batteries themselves
flywheels compressed air storage and
gravitational storage with solid masses
you know some of these like
gravitational storage are emerging
Technologies but you know batteries
exist dams exist pumped Hydro storage
exists concentrated solar power exists
flywheels exist these are all for the
most part existing Technologies and they
can be they have been implemented around
the world for heating and cooling water
tank storage is aluminum presence
everywhere for both hot and cold water
storage and Ice storage and underground
in boreholes water pits and aquifers for
seasonal storage that's a way to store
heat seasonally between summer and
winter and also in building materials
these are for all existing Technologies
and then we'll store some hydrogen so
what are the
people hear a lot about hydrogen these
days so I just want to say in my opinion
what are the good and bad sources and
uses of hydrogen well the only good
source of hydrogen in my belief is green
hydrogen that's hydrogen produced by
electrolysis from wind water solar
electricity
what is not good is hydrogen produced
from natural gas or coal or even Nuclear
So natural gas produced when natural gas
produces hydrogen 96 of all hydrogen
today is produced from what's called
steam methane reforming of natural gas
and that's called gray hydrogen if you
add what's called carbon capture to gray
hydrogen you get blue hydrogen but
carbon capture is not useful it does not
it only takes out carbon from the from
an exhaust stream does not take out any
other air pollutants it takes 30 percent
more energy than if you don't have
carbon capture so that means in the case
of this natural gas you need 30 percent
more Mining and transport and refining
of the natural gas and therefore 30
percent more air pollution 30 percent
more Upstream leaks and the capture
efficiency is not that great it's not a
90 or 95 percent for that type of
capture it's on the order of 60 to 80
percent but in general carbon capture
attached to Coal plants for example can
be the efficiency can be down to 20
percent
in any case you're increasing air
pollution uh with any type of carbon
capture especially when it's added to
including when it's added to a hydrogen
production uh black and brown hydrogen
are from coal we don't want that uh
nuclear electricity using that to
produce hydrogen uh we're going to we're
phasing out nuclear there's hardly any
growth in fact there's less nuclear
produced last year than in 2006 so that
is not growing at all and it takes so
long to put up new nuclear reactors that
they're not an option going forward I'll
mention that a little bit later
turquoise hydrogens from methane methane
pyrolysis again from natural gas we
don't want that what are the good uses
of hydrogen well as I mentioned long
distance uh transport like aircraft
ships trains and trucks for long
distance also military vehicles with
using fuel cells in all cases in
industry for ammonia and steel
manufacturing and also for electricity
and heat using fuel cells for remote
remote microgrids so isolated grids like
in Alaska or it could be in Africa or
anywhere if you need both electricity
and heat which often you do you can get
that from a fuel cell some Grid
electricity but combined with batteries
so having mostly batteries on the grid
but some fuel cells can help out in some
cases for Grid electricity but we do not
want to use hydrogen for passenger
vehicles to heat buildings you don't
want to mix it hydrogen with natural gas
and pipes and we don't want to burn the
hydrogen because it produces air
pollutants and for most great
electricity we'll use batteries and
other types of storage
well okay so why not I talked about wind
water silver but why not carbon capture
direct air capture small modular nuclear
reactors bioenergy non-hydrogen
electrophils or geoengineering well
several of these several of these uh
Technologies they just increase air
pollution I show photos here of air
pollution in the 1950s in Los Angeles
and I show a photo I actually took on
February 19 2023 of Los Angeles we still
have a lot of air pollution in fact
there was a study that came out this
week worldwide there are only five
countries of the world that do not have
harmful air quality in terms of
particles and so there's pollution
rampant around the world to kill seven
million people each year this is a
problem that's continuing and carbon
capture direct air capture bioenergy
electrofuels geoengineering they all
increase air pollution why well as I
mentioned carbon cap picture doesn't
take out any air pollutants from the air
but it needs more energy so 30 percent
more energy if that energy comes from a
fossil fuel you directly have more air
pollution if that energy comes from wind
water and solar well that prevents the
wind water and solar from replacing a
fossil fuel power plant where it could
otherwise eliminate not only the air
pollution from the power plant it could
eliminate the mining of the fuel it
could eliminate the fossil fuel
infrastructure as well and it removes
more CO2 than the carbon capture it
would so there's a there's an
opportunity cost 75 percent of all
carbon dioxide captured today is also
used for enhanced oil recovery during
that process not only do we get more oil
to burn but forty percent of the CO2
that was captured goes right back to the
air so carbon capture is a complete
waste for solving any of these problems
it's an opportunity cost so we do not
want to spend on that direct air capture
is the same as carbon cap except we're
taking carbon dioxide out of the air
directly again you need energy you need
equipment that if that energy comes from
fossil fuels you have more air pollution
directly if it comes from Renewables
then you're preventing those removals
from displacing fossil fuels there by
increasing air pollution in comparison
with replacing the fossil fuels what
about bioenergy you burn it
by over fuel there's biofuels which are
a replacement like ethanol and biodiesel
replacing gasoline and Diesel
respectively you're still burning it and
it takes a lot of energy to produce it
so that energy releases a lot of carbon
in the case of ethanol for example you
can't pipe it around you have to train
truck and Barge it around so that means
more diesel emissions more air pollution
more global warming emissions so the
carbon balance on bioenergy is some
studies show that there's a slight
reduction of carbon compared to gasoline
diesel some studies show there's
actually more carbon emitted so it's
we're not getting anything close to zero
uh we're getting what we are getting
close to zero with electrifying
everything just for example
photosynthesis for producing a biofuel
is one percent Efficient Electric solar
panels are 20 efficient so you get 20
times more energy for the same land when
you put solar panels on that Land versus
growing a bio crop in addition an
electric vehicle uses one-fourth the
energy as a gasoline or ethanol vehicle
so a solar powering an electric vehicle
uses 180th the land to go the same
distance as a biofuel crop powering an
internal combustion engine vehicle
electrofuels non-hydrogen Electro fuels
these are fuels where carbon dioxide is
used with other chemicals and processed
to produce a replacement for gasoline so
not only does that I told you about to
get that carbon dioxide you use carbon
capture which increases air pollution
first of all but then you're creating a
fuel that you're going to burn just like
gasoline so you create the same amount
of pollution it's argued that this
reduces the carbon footprint however it
doesn't as I mentioned it does not
decrease the air pollution and because
you take so much energy to make this
Fuel and it takes a lot of energy to
capture the carbon you're hardly
reducing any carbon from this as well
geoengineering is basically spraying
pollution one of the main solar
radiation management is one of the main
geoengineering techniques that's
basically spraying pollutant particles
into the stratosphere where they can
affect the ozone layer and also reduce
photosynthesis affecting crops at the
surface but what's the big problem with
doing this the goal is to reflect more
sunlight to cool the surface of the
Earth the big problem is it makes people
complacent and allows fossil fuels to
continue
allows air pollution to continue and
grow it allows energy and security to
continue and grow and it has multiple
side effects it doesn't solve any
problem it only masks temperature it
doesn't even address other aspects of
climate change associated with the
increase of fossil fuels so and then
finally small modular nuclear reactors
well conventional nuclear reactors have
a big problem uh new ones it takes 17 to
21 years between planning and operation
for a new nuclear power plant in in
North America and Europe there's a plant
in Georgia it's taking it's on year 17
and 18 for two reactors and it's already
laid a enough concrete for a sidewalk
between Miami and Seattle it costs 34
billion dollars or 2.2 gigawatts that's
that's about 15.2 million dollars a
megawatt compared with one million
dollars a megawatt for wind new wind and
solar and so it's 15 times more the
capital cost about eight times the
electricity cost and it takes 17 to 21
years as I mentioned versus one to three
years for a winter solar we need to
solve 80 percent of the problem within
seven years by 2030 and 100 of the
problem between 2035 and 2050 if we
can't and small modular reactors won't
even be available for testing until 2030
they've already been studied for 10
years so they have the same delay
problem their cost problem is similar to
the conventional reactors and plus
there's energy security risk of nuclear
weapons proliferation risk waste issues
meltdown risk uranium mining lung cancer
risks and also CO2 there's CO2 emissions
associated with nuclear it's about 9 to
37 times the CO2 emissions per kilowatt
hour as wind most of that's due to the
fact that it takes so long to build it
you're waiting you're burning fuels
fossil fuels in the background
okay so let's let's move on I want to
summarize really quickly this is a just
an example of District heating this is
Stanford University where I work
um replaced the natural gas cogeneration
plant uh with this that which provided
80 of the campus electricity and heat
with this fourth generation District
heating and cooling system they let out
35 miles of cold water pipes 35 miles of
hot water pipes and that uh and now
provides 100 of the heating and cooling
of the University with this District
heating cooling system and bought
sufficient solar 160 megawatts to power
not only this system but all the
electricity for the campus so it was the
first campus in the world to be 100
renewable for electricity Heating and
Cooling this is another type of District
heating system this is underground
borehole system in Okotoks Canada where
there are 52 homes that have solar
collectors on their garages are on the
roofs of their garages on the top left
where a glycol solution is heated up
during the summer and transferred by
pipe to this building on the right where
the heat is transferred to water the
water is piped underground and set
through boreholes to the soil the heat
is stored six months up to six months
and then in the winter when the snow is
on the ground like in the bottom left
everything is run in Reverse so to
provide 100 of the wintertime heating at
less than one dollar a kilowatt hour of
heat storage which Compares with about
100 to 200 a kilowatt hour for
electricity storage
we can transition individual homes and
buildings I just want to say something
this is my own home in 2017 I built it
with no gas on the property I have solar
on the roofs batteries in the garage
electric cars these are electric heat
pumps that I don't have time to go into
but they transfer the transfer heat
rather than produce it and as a result
these one-fourth the energy is natural
gas here's a heat pump water heater that
uses one fourth of the energy of it as a
natural gas water heater an electric
induction cooktop stove it boils water
in half the time of this gas and you
know these all these Technologies are
really efficient so over the five first
five years of energy use like produce
120 percent of all my home and vehicle
energy needs with the solar on the roof
I had no electric bill no natural gas
bill or gasoline bill I received money
back for the extra electricity from the
Community Choice aggregation utility
that I subscribe to
but I also avoided a gas hookup fee of
about six thousand dollars this shows a
range for typical homes and gas pipes of
about ten thousand dollars you don't
need two forms of energy in your home or
building electricity does everything
that gas does but does it better so
after all the savings were accounted for
it's a five-year payback time with
subsidies that are also available in
California in the United States and
about 10 years without subsidies the
solar is warranted for 25 years so right
now it's free energy for the next uh 20
years
okay can we transition the world for all
purposes uh to win water and solar so we
did studies of 145 countries in all 50
states let me just summarize the results
quickly the end use demand among all
these countries in 2018 was 13 trillion
Watts or terawatts that's expected to go
up to 20.4 terawatts by 2050 but if we
Electrify everything and provide the
electricity with wind water solar that
goes down 56.4 percent to 8.9 terawatts
for five reasons one is that battery
electric and hydrogen fuel cell Vehicles
use less energy much less energy than
internal combustion engine vehicles
the electrifying industry uses less
energy than fossil fuel industry using
heat pumps for air and water heating
reduce energy requirements 13.6 across
all energy sectors
and then 11.3 percent of all energy
worldwide is used to mine transport and
refine fossil fuels and uranium this
goes out the door we don't need that
mining anymore for those purposes so
that's 11.3 and then we think we can get
another 6.6 efficiency improvements
Beyond business as usual so that 56
percent
reduction significantly makes it easier
to to provide enough energy for the
world with just wind water solar this
shows a timeline of the same information
from 2020 to 2050. if we don't do
anything we go along the top line but if
we Electrify and provide the electricity
with wws we go down those five shades of
colors to the 100 wws line and then we
provide that wind water solar with
onshore and offshore wind Etc in the
mixes shown this show is an 80
transition by 2030 and 100 by 2050 which
is needed to avoid 1.5 degrees or more
global warming since the 1850 to 1900
period however if we can solve 80 of the
problem by 2030 there's no reason we
shouldn't be able to solve 100 by 2035
which is or really should be our goal we
have 95 percent of the technologies that
we need right now
and well you might ask is there enough
land to do this uh so for those 135 145
Country plans we find that well we we
don't need new land for offshore wind
tidal wave power or rooftop PV we're not
adding new Hydro in any of these plans
geothermal editions are small so the new
land required is for utility quotable
takes plus concentrated solar power
which we call Footprints so that
worldwide is about 0.17 percent of world
land will be needed and then the spacing
between onshore wind turbines which can
be used for farming ranching open space
or even some of the some of the PV so
that's about 0.36 percent so a total of
0.53 so around half of one percent of
the world's land in the U.S that would
be about 0.84 in comparison the fossil
fuel industry occupies about 1.3 percent
of the U.S land area so we think we'll
go down
can we keep the grid stable yes we can
we've done grid stability analyzes and
not only for all the 145 countries
broken into or divided into 24 World
regions but also all U.S states here so
here for example is the continental U.S
a grid stability analysis finding that
we can keep the grid stable uh every 30
seconds for two years here with just
wind water solar storage and using
demand response what's the cost of
energy with such a conversion in keeping
the grid stable well the capital cost
worldwide is around 62 trillion dollars
this is what I call the worldwide Green
New Deal cost in the U.S it's about nine
trillion dollars and in China it's about
13 trillion dollars but what's really
more important is the annual cost of
energy comparison with businesses as
usual today worldwide we spend about 11
to 12 trillion dollars per year on
energy that's expected to go up to 18
trillion dollars per year by 2050.
the health costs around 33.6 trillion
dollars per year in 2050 the climate
cost around 32 trillion that's a total
social cost of 83 trillion dollars
if we go to windwater solar for
everything we eliminate the health and
climate costs of energy and our energy
requirements go down 56 percent and the
cost per unit energy goes down another
15 so we go from 17.8 trillion in the
energy cost to 6.6 trillion or 63
percent lower and our total social cost
goes down 92 percent these are
phenomenal reductions uh due to going to
wind water solar and finally I just want
to say something about uh policy we
developed our first energy plan in 2009
uh and it was really a world plan
without looking at individual countries
and the conclusion was well it's
technically an economically possible to
transition the World by 2030 to wind
water and solar but for social and
political reasons a more likely
transition is by 2050 with most 80 by
2030. this turned out to be the basis
for the green New Deal this this
scientific study but since then they're
now 62 countries that have committed to
100 Renewables in the electric power
sector only one country Denmark has
committed to 100 Renewables in all
energy sectors there are in the US there
are 19 States and territories and
districts that have committed to 100
percent uh Renewables in the electric
power sector again these are not all
sectors and I'm just going to run
through these really quick to get to the
end there are 180 plus cities and
counties in the U.S that have committed
to 100 Renewables uh these are really
important the blue ones are the bigger
cities
there are over 400 international
companies that have committed included
including 100 sorry to eight of the ten
biggest companies of the world which
were the ones in blue
uh and there are also countries in state
and states that are actually already at
100 on the left very left there are nine
countries that actually generate 100 of
their electricity already from wind
water solar the middle three countries
generate 91 or more of their electricity
from wind water solar most of these are
generating primarily with hydropower uh
Kenya has geothermal on the right or
South Dakota is actually generating 126
percent of its consumed energy with wind
water solar with 77 percent wind and the
rest hydro and it also produces fossil
fuels so it exports the difference
Washington State's at 98.5 percent
Scotland's around 91 as is Montana so
these are all good uh this is all good
news so just to summarize uh we also
think we can create jobs with a
transition 28 million more long-term
full-time jobs than lost we require like
point five three percent of land for
such a transition worldwide we'd avoid 7
million deaths per year we'd slow than
reverse global warming we think we can
keep the grid stable with 100 wind water
and solar energy costs are 63 percent
lower annual energy plus Health Plus
climate costs are 92 percent lower than
with fossil fuels and finally for more
information as Anita said there's an
online course that discusses this in a
lot more depth uh there's a new book
called No Miracles needed that is a
Layman's book summarizing that that we
don't need miracle Technologies to
transition it gives us an example of how
how we can transition and we have
individual State and country and city
plans at the third uh link and there is
actually an infographic map where you
can click on a map and upload each of
these uh plans if you're interested and
and happy to answer any questions that
you might have thank you very much
mark thank you so much there's so much
to be covered here
um this is so important and
um I just want to I'm looking at all the
questions and I have to just make this
uh known out to our audience that many
of your questions mark teaches in his
exeit 100 course and he goes into deep
detail that course is the foundation
course for our energy Innovation and
emerging Technologies program
um and it's com it's comprehensive it
covers all the Technologies uh policy uh
impacts to humanity and uh to people all
around the globe I have one question
here that I I know you dress in the
course but it would be interesting to to
hear your answer at this point with the
transition of what's happening with
hydrogen and the question question is
specifically for using hydrogen in uh
passenger vehicles uh is a straight
electric vehicles
yeah so the reason we don't want to use
hydrogen in passenger vehicles
it's not because it's not clean it
actually is clean if we use green
hydrogen in passenger vehicles it's
almost as clean as using battery
electric and the only the difference is
though you need about two to three times
the number of wind turbines or solar
panels to run that hydrogen fuel cell
vehicle versus the battery electric
vehicle so it's it's so you'll need more
land and you'll there's a little more
emissions in building these turbines and
so it just makes the transition more
difficult so if we want to be really
efficient we need to focus the hydrogen
on useful applications it turns out when
you get to larger and larger Vehicles
the efficiency turns and the hydrogen
fuel cell Vehicles become more efficient
than battery electrics when you get to
like long distance aircraft and ships
just because otherwise you're carrying
you're spending a lot of energy just
carrying around batteries and that's
that that's the case where you want to
use a hydrogen for those long distance
applications
great
um we have one minute left and I want to
thank you and thank everybody who
attended today and uh if you have other
questions you can always reach out to us
through our email which is on the EIT
program website
um and um you can see on your screen if
you would like to enroll on the course
you should be able to select one of the
links there to learn about Mark's course
Mark I want to thank you again for
joining us today and giving us this so
very important and excellent webinar and
I want to thank everybody else who took
the time to join us today from wherever
you are in in the world it has been an
absolute pleasure and we hope you all
have a great rest of your day